Okay, switching gears now. Joining me
this time is someone who's definitely
not a Mameluke. Joining me from New York
City is the director of Jihad Watch,
Robert Spencer. Robert, welcome back to
the show. It's a pleasure to be here.
Thank you. All right, Robert. So,
we're hearing about the threat of ISIS
on our homeland. There are reports that
there may be as many as a
100 ISIS sympathizers
in America that have gone to fight or
about to
leave America to go fight alongside of
ISIS in the Middle East. Is that number
low, high, sound about right to you?
I think it's low. Unfortunately, it
seems as if there's quite a lot of
interest among young American Muslims
for the Islamic State.
Clearly, the idea of the restored
caliphate has captured the imaginations
of many young Muslims. We have never
seen this kind of interest in the United
States in joining Al-Qaeda. There were
only a handful of Muslims from the
United States who did that. And of
course, last year there were some
Muslims from Minneapolis who were Somali
who were going back to Somalia to join
Al-Shabaab, the Jihad terror group
there. But we have never seen this kind
of interest with businessmen like Mufid
Elfgeeh in Rochester, New York who ran a
successful restaurant. He
now is charged with trying to aid the
Islamic State. Halima Conley, formerly
Shannon Conley in Colorado, a young
woman who had just converted to Islam
now pleaded guilty to trying to join the
Islamic State.
This is something that we've never seen
in this kind of numbers. No. I think
it's only going to grow and authorities
have every reason to lowball it since
they are denying the threat altogether.
Only going to grow. That that is a
troubling
point at the end of your at the end of
your comment there. What is driving
these individuals, Robert Spencer? What
is motivating them? It's my
understanding mostly the individuals are
under the age of 35.
Why? Is it You talk about the restaurant
owner.
It sort of defies defies the logic. I
mean,
a lot of people are comparing this to to
youth who are sort of
disenfranchised from society, from from
having any
group of group support group. And
oftentimes people join the Bloods and
the Crips that have that sort of
background of
family support group in place.
Is it like that?
Well,
actually, unfortunately, a lot of these
people are quite successful.
There have been many, many people who
are wealthy and who are well-educated
who have gone from around the world from
Britain, from France, from Germany, as
well as from the United States to join
the Islamic State. The appeal of this is
in this caliphate idea. The caliphate is
supposed to be the unified government of
all the Muslims with the caliph being
the successor of Muhammad as the
spiritual, political, and military
leader of the Muslims. And the caliph
There has There hasn't been a caliphate
or a caliph since 1924 when the office
was abolished by the secular Turkish
government. And that has been grievance
number one of all the Jihad terror
groups. One of the main things that they
all lament about Al-Qaeda, Hamas,
Hezbollah, you name it. They lament that
there is no unity among the Muslims,
that there's no caliphate, and one of
their principal goals has been to
restore the caliphate, but nobody has
managed to do it in any convincing way
up until the advent of this group. Yeah.
And that's why this group is so
appealing. You know, Robert, everything
about it is is troubling, but again, one
of the key points you make is that these
are successful people traveled around
the world. There was a time not so long
ago very in our very short history where
we we as Americans believed that by and
large when people immigrate here from
another nation and they see the freedom
and the openness of of our society,
they distance them themselves from the
values of other more oppressive
cultures.
And perhaps we we speculated that is why
we haven't seen some of the terror
attacks on on US soil that Europeans and
other other countries have seen
other continents have seen. But it feels
like sadly that notion may be from a
bygone era of like six, seven, eight
years ago. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I mean,
really multiculturalism, the idea that
immigrants should not try to assimilate,
but should bring their cultures to their
new country has been very, very damaging
in this particular respect because we're
talking about people who are coming from
societies that consider themselves to be
they they they have they have a These
immigrants are the first immigrant group
who have a ready-made model of society
and governance that they are taught
to consider to be superior to the model
of the country to which they are coming.
And of course, when the country to which
they are coming is teaching them, well,
we're all multiculturalists and you
retain your own culture, this is very
dangerous and very damaging. And we see
it in Europe with the Sharia enclaves
where in increasing numbers of cities in
Europe, there are Muslim areas where
the Islamic law prevails and the law of
the government, the the law of the land
just is not paid attention to. And
authorities have not yet had the will to
do anything to enforce the idea that
there's single law for all the citizens
of the country. This is the kind of
thing that's going to happen here if
we're not careful. All right, switching
gears now. An important topic not
getting talked about in the media and we
want to bring it up. Some people will
say, well, you know, if you're in the
media and you bring this up,
you shouldn't you know, you might get
repercussions. We're going to
hit it square on with you, Robert
Spencer. We're going to Robert Spencer
and we're going to continue to square on
in the show in the weeks ahead. And that
is this. Right now, Comcast is in on
Capitol Hill meeting in front of
Congress about they want to buy Time
Warner. And why that is important ties
into a bigger story. Al Jazeera. Al
Jazeera is a Qatar or Cutter, however
they pronounce it, owned organization.
Al Jazeera is described by our FBI our
very own FBI as as a
Osama bin Laden sympathizer. Al Jazeera
has direct contacts to the Muslim
Brotherhood. And Al Jazeera, by the way,
is carried by Comcast, is carried by
Time Warner. By the way, DirectTV and
Dish and these cable companies are for
are forcing their customers to pay extra
to have Al Jazeera brought into their
homes.
Am I over exaggerating
Al Jazeera's connections to terrorist
ties and money? No, not at all. Not at
all, Rick. There have been Al Jazeera
reporters who've been arrested for Jihad
terror activity.
Al Jazeera is closely connected to the
Muslim Brotherhood operatives who have
been operating for years in Qatar.
Sheikh Yusuf al-Qaradawi is the most
renowned and prominent Islamic cleric in
the entire world. He is banned from
entering the United States for endorsing
Jihad suicide bombing attacks against
American soldiers. He has praised Hitler
and called for Muslims to finish
Hitler's work and kill Jews Jews
wholesale. This is a deeply noxious,
evil character and he's closely
connected with the Qatar government and
with Al Jazeera. And the Muslim
Brotherhood has been given
extraordinarily favorable coverage as
well as other Jihad terror groups by Al
Jazeera. It's essentially
the propaganda network for the global
Jihad. And so, the idea that Americans
would have to pay more for this, it's
it's a scandal. And and I want to point
out, Al Jazeera has been kicked out of
Egypt by the Egyptian government.
All right, so we'll continue this
conversation in the weeks ahead,
Robert Spencer, because it's an
important one. Again, American cable
companies, and you may call it Al
Jazeera America, but it's all the same
thing. I mean, it's it's it's part of Al
Jazeera which is backed by Qatar money
which is in bed with the Muslim
Brotherhood, which is why Egypt kicked
them out. And and all the points which
you make, and American cable companies
Comcast, Time Warner, Direct, Dish are
charging their
customers more
so that Al Jazeera can be carried on
those providers. And some of those same
providers have not yet made a decision
on
a American-owned network like One
American News. Robert Spencer of Jihad
Watch, the director, we thank you for
joining us.